[Música]
en Estados Unidos avanza el recuento de
los votos de las elecciones de medio
término los republicanos están a Solo
siete escaños del control de la cámara
de representantes mientras que los
demócratas a un solo escaños de
controlar el senado analizamos el tema
en unos minutos
en Perú restan algunos requisitos
legales para que pase a votación ante el
pleno del Congreso el proceso con el que
buscan inhabilitar por cinco años al
presidente Pedro castillo y también
acusarlo de traición a la patria
y se mantiene tensa la relación entre
Italia y Francia después del rechazo
italiano de recibir el barco Ocean
biking con migrantes a bordo que
finalmente tuvo que atracar en las
costas francesas este país intensificó
los controles en su frontera con Italia
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de Franz 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos en donde avanza lentamente el
recuento de los votos de las elecciones
de medio término veamos a esta hora cómo
está configurada entonces las dos
cámaras con las votaciones que han
resultado hasta el momento los en
republicanos están a sólo siete escaños
de lograr la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes mientras que los
demócratas necesitan solo un escaño para
hacerse con el control completo del
senado es allí en la cámara alta en
donde ambos partidos cuentan ahora con
49 senadores un movimiento
en cuanto a ese equilibrio lo puede
hacer el estado de Nevada que es el
único estado que resta por entregar de
manera oficial los resultados En caso
que Nevada de una victoria a los
demócratas el partido del presidente Joe
biden pasaría a tener el control del
senado contando también con el voto que
recibe de la vicepresidenta kamala así
las cosas el escenario en el senado
sería bastante parecido a la
configuración que tenía la cámara alta
antes de estos comicios
Muy bien pues vamos a analizar Entonces
los escenarios posibles para esta recta
final del recuento de los votos en
Estados Unidos para eso saludamos al
señor José Jesús Hernández Contreras él
es analista político muy buenas noches
señor
Gracias por estar con nosotros señor
Contreras Gracias por estar con nosotros
en francés 24 y por qué el retraso en el
recuento en el estado de Nevada y qué es
lo que falta por contabilizar allí Cuál
es el análisis
hay mucha manera en primero Muchas
gracias por la presentación y hay muchas
maneras de realizar la situación que
vive en los Estados Unidos de su proceso
electorales los estados en su proceso
electorales no son un solo proceso
electoral Federal como es la mayoría de
los países por ejemplo Brasil acaba de
tener un proceso electoral de más de 100
millones de votantes dio los resultados
en dos horas y la diferencia es mínima
pero la dio el problema es que los
Estados Unidos los resultados y todas
las juntas electorales son federales y
federales son no son federales no son
estatales y no son estatales sino son
municipales cada municipio tiene un
mecanismo de conteo específico cada
municipio tiene un proceso de conteo
específico y cada situación es
completamente diferente porque se tardan
muchas veces porque en algunos casos los
las boletas ausentes la boletas que
llegan por correo son leídas después del
día electoral o sea después de que se
finalice el proceso electoral y otros
casos se leen antes de que empiece el
proceso electoral y cuando empieza el
proceso electoral simplemente se añade
ese ese número si eso se ha ido
corrigiendo con el tiempo en algunos
casos mejor que en otros por ejemplo la
Florida después del año 2000 en las
elecciones entre los presidentes Gold y
Bush en dos candidatos por favor y bus
te corrigió el problema de manera del
Estado completo Sí entonces
me va a llegar a Arizona eso todavía no
ocurre señor Hernández hemos dicho que
la atención está concentrada en el
estado de Nevada Qué tendencia política
tiene este estado y que resultado
podríamos esperar allí un apoyo para los
republicanos o apoyo para los demócratas
dependiendo de esta tendencia marcada
que tenga el estado Nevada está muy
tiene un sentido muy cambiante porque es
un estado donde hay mucho cambio de
población es un estado de mucho
crecimiento económico y de mucha
situación particularmente
que mejora la gente la condición de la
gente entonces mucha gente en los
Estados Unidos en el proceso migración
interna de los Estados Unidos migra a
los Estados deliadas así como miran a
los estados de Texas del estado de
Florida
elevada el candidato gobernador
demócrata ya concedió al candidato
gobernador republicano y las elecciones
para leer el senado están Colgando de un
0,1% creo que la cifra está por debajo
de los de los cientos de votos O sea no
llega ni a los miles de votos entre los
dos candidatos y la senadora que está
actualmente es la que van en ascenso
pero es la que está atrás entonces la
eso colocaría la votación en 50 y 50 y
hay un pronóstico que es el estado de
Georgia que se encuentra que se contaría
dentro de 60 días lo cual significa que
es que quede
51 a 49 por ejemplo señor Hernández
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en France 24 haber hecho este
análisis para nuestra audiencia Muchas
gracias gracias
pasamos ahora a Perú en donde hay
reacciones después de las aprobaciones
de un informe que solicita que el
presidente Pedro Castillo sea
inhabilitado por 5 años y se le acuse
también por el delito de traición a la
patria dicho proceso deberá cumplir
otros requisitos legales antes de su
eventual votación en el congreso peruano
desde Lima Francisco Zacarías nos da más
información el presidente Pedro Castillo
ha sido citado por el congreso de Perú
el miércoles 16 de noviembre a una
sesión de la comisión permanente del
parlamento para el debate y votación de
la denuncia constitucional por traición
a la patria en su contra que fue
aprobada por la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales el
mandatario tendrá una hora para ejercer
su defensa si es que la comisión
permanente la denuncia se convocará el
pleno del congreso para una sesión de
debate y votación donde se requieren 66
votos para inhabilitar a Pedro Castillo
Al respecto del mandatario ha dicho que
han inventado denuncias y carpetas
constitucionales en su contra pero nunca
tendrán la razón por su parte la defensa
del gobernante rechaza el proceso porque
afirma que el congreso peruano no puede
aplicar el delito de traición a la
patria cuando no existe una sentencia de
por medio contra Pedro Castillo mientras
que diversos juristas sostienen que la
denuncia no tiene sustento legal porque
jamás entregó territorio peruano a
Bolivia y la denuncia puede jugar a
favor del presidente Castillo para
mostrar a la misión de la oea de que
existe la convicción de la oposición
para sacarlo del Poder De cualquier
forma los incondicionales de Pedro
Castillo confían en que una acción de
Amparo del mandatario contra el congreso
que fue admitido a trámite Por una corte
pueda frenar la denuncia por traición a
la patria y una eventual tercera Mo de
vacancia presidencial en otros temas las
relaciones entre Francia e Italia están
cada vez más tensas después de la
decisión del gobierno de la primera
ministra Georgia meloni de no recibir el
barco con migrantes el Ocean viking que
terminó llegando finalmente a costas
francesas el gobierno del presidente
Manuel macocó ha intensificado los
controles fronterizos entre los dos
países para evitar entre otras cosas el
aumento del contrabando cerca de las
ciudades de mantón y ventimiglia en la
frontera Franco italiana se intensifican
los controles los guardias fronterizos y
la policía están deteniendo a los coches
procedentes de Italia nos piden que
abramos el maletero y revisen nuestras
identificaciones las tensiones entre
Francia e Italia aumentan a causa del
Ocean biking un barco con 230
inmigrantes que finalmente ha podido
atracar en Tulum el Ministerio del
interior francés ha desplegado 500
agentes más para ayudar a realizar las
inspecciones fronterizas en la región el
refuerzo de chequeos implica mayores
esperas para los conductores
creo que Francia hace bien en limitar un
poco a todos estos inmigrantes que
vienen aquí y creo que cuando la policía
está aquí no puede estar allí hay otras
tareas más importantes para ellos que
permanecer en un puesto fronterizo
está
Los contrabandistas también son buscados
en estos controles desde principios de
años se ha detenido a 680 de ellos a
pesar de la posibilidad de cinco años de
cárcel y 300.000 euros de multas y son
detenidos su número va en aumento
Los contrabandistas pueden ser guías en
los senderos pueden ser personas que van
a buscar en vehículos privados pero
también pueden ser robos en camiones de
transporte
otro foco la estación de tren de
mantonga gabán
el tren de cercanías que viene de Italia
espera 15 minutos más
tarjeta de identidad pasaporte por favor
el retraso molesta algunos pasajeros
estoy en contra de este tipo de control
dificulta la libre circulación los
automovilistas y pasajeros de tren que
se dirigen a la frontera tendrán que
acostumbrarse a esperas más largas ya
que se prevé que la situación no cambia
en los próximos días
y tras La retirada de las tropas rusas
avanza la retoma ucraniana en la ciudad
de gerson en la jornada de hoy unos 200
policías ingresaron a la ciudad y
volvieron a emitir las estaciones de
radio y de la televisión ucraniana entre
tanto el kremlin insiste en que el
retiro de las tropas no cambia el
estatus de esta región que ya fue
anexada de manera unilateral a Rusia
la celebración de una reconquista El
regreso del ejército ucraniano a la
ciudad de personas ha sido catalogado
como la mayor victoria de kiev desde que
inició la invasión hace ocho meses Rusia
dijo que retiró a más de 30.000
militares de la urbe hacia la otra
orilla del río niepera
los ciudadanos esperaron nunca
repudiaron a Ucrania tenían razones
depositar sus esperanzas en Ucrania y
Ucrania siempre devuelve las suyas me
alegra ver a esa gente a pesar de todos
los peligros la represión y el
sufrimiento infligido por los ocupantes
que se aferran a las banderas ucranianas
en el centro de kiev cientos se
reunieron el viernes por la noche para
celebrar la noticia muchos son
originarios de gerson pero que huyeron
cuando las fuerzas rusas los invadieron
en marzo
Ginger son muchos empiezan a regresar a
sus hogares o lo que queda de ellos los
rusos destruyeron y saquearon casas pero
no todo se fueron como esta granjera que
recuerdan los angustiosos momentos que
vivió durante la ocupación
los el camino
nos las culatas de los rifles los rusos
dañaron las casas de los que sirvieron a
su ejército y se llevaron los bienes de
las mejores casas
jerson fue la única gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos enemigas
Rusia sigue controlando alrededor del
60% de la región que lleva el mismo
nombre incluida la costa del mar de azul
y que fue anexionada ilegalmente junto a
otras tres por Moscú el principal punto
de acceso a la ciudad cruzando el río
nieper era el puente anthonynsky ahora
destruido según lo confirmado por
imágenes satelitales imágenes que
también señalan nuevos daños en La
Represa de novakahofka al norte de
gerson y cuya eventual voladura
generaría desastrosas inundaciones en el
país
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
recuerde que más información la
encuentran también en nuestra página web
France 24.com también en las redes
sociales nos vemos cada 30 minutos aquí
actualizando los con los hechos más
destacados de la jornada siga con
nosotros
[Música]